does being an artist mean that you have
to be broke nobody usually that's being
that you end up hope that's funny and do
you have to be but there are some people
that have this romantic idea with being
the starving artist and I can't think of
anything less romantic that it broke so
I don't think it's necessary but I do
think that art isn't known for making
people a lot of money in the early
stages it just doesn't I mean you have
to develop a following guitar it's very
hard to make money with a part so I
think they end up broke and that kind of
interesting a nastiness because I've
lived kind of a different life I always
focused on the practical side and you
know if you want to be successful in the
entertainment business you gotta have
talent that that's important timing is
important the guy who misses the talk
radio home by about a decade maybe if
I've gotten in ten years ago before
there was 5,000 conservative talk show
hosts out there there's only a couple
you know you know you're about Rush and
blend Hannity and then you've got you
hear Mark Levin here Sam Michael Savage
you've got those guys that have made it
in the national syndicated level but I
kind of missed that window by about ten
years so it's nothing it's not new
anymore so timing is important as well
and then finally of willingness to do
whatever it takes and so the question
then becomes how long were you willing
and how would you personally define
whatever it takes in my case I was never
willing to be that starving artist I
just didn't want it I didn't I
even if you look at bands like there
were 80 rock bands like poison Motley
Crue they talked about those lean years
they weren't ten years there were a year
or two or three
then they weren't living in rat-infested
you know warehouses for a decade
straight if you're if that's your line
you're probably doing something wrong
you don't have to suffer in misery and
be broke I don't believe for ten years
now you might choose to because you
think just oh I just hold out a little
bit longer but probably something needs
to change in your approach or what
you're offering maybe it's not working I
mean look I had to come to the
realization that you know from a radio
standpoint that on XM the audience was
so big and I don't mean so big I'm more
like it's only so big and only gonna get
so far on this platform and I realized
that it was time to cool off so I made
the choice to move the show at some
other opportunities that I'm pursuing
that might prove that situation so you
have to either be willing to say okay
this plan isn't working from a from the
standpoint of how long it's different
for everybody I wasn't willing to do
whatever it takes in other words be
broke for a decade move all around the
country it just didn't make sense to me
because I knew that I'd be better
equipped to accomplish what I want to
accomplish in life if I was also making
money so that's why I made the
transition to advertising sales because
financially I could live a great
lifestyle and I can still pursue it as a
hobby there comes a point where you have
to grow up I think if you want to have a
wife maybe if you know what if you don't
want to be married and you never want to
have kids and all you want to do is just
pursue your art then go for that's
that's a valid choice it's not my choice
but it's a valid one you have that right
but you can't say well I want to have
this certain lifestyle why have Y for
one if kids should be broke for 20 years
me that's to me that's not a good plan
to me that's not living a dream to me
that's living a nightmare
so in my purse
life I chose to work a corporate job
make my money and then pursue my hobbies
and interests and if they worked out
great but you know that's just me I mean
I'm more practical
you